auditors are in the spotlight at the
moment following the collapse of
Karelian and other accounting scandals
while the industry watchdog the
financial reporting Council is under far
as well for its record in supervising
them well the UK's number 5 player grant
thornton has said it will no longer
compete with the so-called big four last
Deloitte eey KPMG and PwC for audit
contracts from the UK's largest 350
companies so it's the audit marketplace
in this country functioning properly and
do we need more competition and even
regulation well joining me now is grant
Thornton's CEO Sascha romanovitch such a
really appreciate you joining me why did
you take this decision well it was a
really a strategic decision for us you
know we know that we have scale and
capability to look at some of the most
complex work in the UK we've done the
ring-fencing assurance on Barclays we're
market leader in the public sector and
yet in this footsie 350 marketplace
despite the rotation rules that came in
in 2016
and I was tendering for many
opportunities we've only won two in that
period and we just decided that actually
it was better focusing our time and
resources on an advisory work in that
marketplace where we could actually make
a difference so that's how you replace
any lost revenue yeah I mean to be fair
it's not about losing revenue you know
we will continue to serve the clients
that we already act for in that
marketplace it's much more about saying
look it's much better to direct the
resources that serving the clients and
winning clients where they want to work
with this rather than keeping beating
the door where they don't this is pretty
terrible in terms of what it says about
the UK audit market and competitiveness
I mean here you are one of the sort of
challenger brands and you're basically
saying we can't compete with the big big
guys I think the interesting thing is in
terms of competition you know for the
footsie 350 the large four firms have
over ninety nine ninety eight percent
market share and I think it's time for
the competent Competition Commission to
actually have another look at that and
see how that how can they change things
I mean the also the financial reporting
Council told the Financial Times the
other day be almost favoured breaking
the the big four up I mean do you go
along with that well I think that's
actually conflating issues you know
that's on a very different issue which
is a
and conflict of interest how do you
ensure you're not marking your own
homework and so I don't think that's a
solution to the issue that we're talking
about and I also think it's important
that particularly where the UK is in the
global economy that we widen this debate
to actually talk about you know this
isn't just about competition this is
about what is the role of audit and
assurance in ensuring trust and
integrity and markets for us to be a
really viable global center well clearly
that trust has been eroded by scandals
like the collapse of Karelian hasn't it
although I think you know I think again
I think it's important to say you know
when you look around the world there
will always be corporate failings and
looking specifically at what is the role
of assurance we currently have an
assurance an audit such your deep
product that is designed to do to not do
the two things that actually the market
continuous for which is can you detect
fraud and can you guarantee me that this
business will continue those are things
that specifically a statue audit does
not do as it stands so the whole
system's dysfunction it's not just a
lack of competition yeah I think you
have got these three different issues
which is what is what do we really need
going forward into the future to
actually give trust and integrity beyond
just what
shareholders are looking for but why do
stakeholders you've got how do you make
sure you haven't got a conflicts of
interest and you've got a competition we
mustn't complete the three so what are
your ideas on those so I think that I
think the key thing is I think that you
know doing a review of competition is
important but I think the really
critical one is let's step back let's
take the opportunity to look at how the
UK could be world leading in creating an
assurance framework that is fit for the
future and there's a lot of opportunity
there to make a difference unless you
say you met you mentioned the rotation
rules of while ago I mean at the moment
big companies they have to put out their
audit contract for tender every ten
years and then rotate them every 20
years is that too short a time frame do
you think or sort of rather too long not
necessarily I mean you know rotation was
really trying to actually deal with two
separate things one is trying to make
sure that people weren't getting too
familiar so falling into the marking
your own homework and the other to open
up competition but I think that's
it's owners a measure is never going to
really make a difference the FRC itself
I mean obviously the politicians are
gunning for it now I mean it is it fit
for purpose and there's a there are real
questions about its regulatory capture
and the number of ex big fall partners
who are on its board and big big shots
at the FRC yeah I'm again you know I
think that you know all of us need to
look at that are we marking or I own own
homework
including the FRC but again I think it's
looking at what is what what is a fit
for purpose regulator how do they focus
on the areas of biggest risk and you
know as their scope the span of controls
extended you know there has to be a
question in terms of what is assurance
for how do we stratify the market so
we're focusing on where it will make the
biggest difference and also reinventing
how that works in a digital world and so
I think again there's the opportunity to
relook at it and really think about how
we can transform to be fit for the
future romanovitch we've got to leave it
there afraid great to see thank you